Воєнний стан запроваджено в Україні вперше.
Як нові реалії можуть вплинути на економіку і життя пересічних українців?
Розмови про воєнний стан вже спровокували послаблення гривні.
На тлі панічних настроїв напередодні обмінники та комерційні банки
підвищили курс гривні долара подекуди до майже 30 гривень.
Тим часом, у Нацбанку запевнили:
готові завадити різким "стрибкам" курсу
і підтримати гривню інтервенціями.
Хоча і закликали голів найбільших банків
вчасно наповнювати банкомати готівкою,
ймовірно, аби завадити панічним настроям у суспільстві.
Ще один важливий аспект - співпраця з Міжнародним валютним фондом.
Після запровадження воєнного стану переговори з МВФ триватимуть,
оскільки формально юридичних обмежень щодо продовження співпраці з Україною установа не має.
Однак оглядачі сумніваються у майбутній успішній співпраці.
Адже МВФ може мати сумніви:
чи запроваджено воєнний стан задля безпеки країни,
чи задля підсилення позицій влади на виборах.
Окрім того, після запровадження воєнного стану
великий бізнес навряд чи ризикуватиме інвестувати в Україну,
адже багато хто з бізнесменів сприйматиме її
як країну де ось-ось може розпочатися велика війна.
Такий сценарій може спровокувати відтік капіталу з країни,
що збільшить дефіцит платіжного балансу,
і як наслідок, призведе до зменшення золотовалютних резервів
та падіння курсу національної валюти.
Ще до запровадження воєнного стану українські чиновники запевняли,
що новий правовий режим не вплине на роботу важливих функцій держави.
І зарплати, і пенсії влада пообіцяла виплачувати без збоїв.
Якщо воєнний стан триватиме не довше запланованих 30 днів,
держбюджет, за словами оглядачів, не переглядатимуть.
Відповідно, залишиться в силі зростання мінімальної зарплати, пенсій і гроші на субсидії.
Якщо ж воєнний стан триватиме значно довше,
тоді кошти здебільшого йтимуть на оборонний сектор,
а програми, спрямовані, приміром, на медицину, освіту,
збільшення виплат - будуть скорочені.
Запровадження воєнного стану не має суттєво вплинути на ціни на продукти -
принаймні, такі прогнози дають експерти.
Втім, вони не виключають, що через паніку,
якій населення піддається дуже легко,
українці активно скуповуватимуть провізію,
а це може спровокувати підвищення цін та інфляцію.
Тим часом, у Міністерстві агрополітики запевнили:
воєнний стан не вплине на забезпечення продуктами.
А пропозиція основних продуктів значно перевищує прогнозований попит.
Зміни через запровадження воєнного стану торкнуться і залізниці.
Підприємство працюватиме в особливому режимі,
щоб забезпечити перевезення для потреб оборони.
В "Укрзалізниці" запевнили:
пасажирські і вантажні потяги їздитимуть за графіком
та усіма незабороненими маршрутами.
Втім оглядачі сумніваються, що затримок чи інших збоїв вдасться уникнути.